hey you guys this is yet another episode
of flickers of fear or is that just what
they want you to think
sorry i couldn't resist
okay all bullshittery aside
uh today we are talking about a movie
called the conspiracy which came out
i think it actually like the copyright
date on it at the end of the credits i
think said 2012 but i don't think it got
a wide release until 2013.
um i don't know imdb has it listed as
2012. so that's when i'm gonna list it
as as well now this is a movie that i
had heard about
i didn't hear about it like back when it
first came out because i think it
premiered at fantastic fest but over the
subsequent years i kept seeing it pop up
on you know lists of best horror of the
21st century best found footage movie
stuff like that now if anybody knows
anything about me or has watched this
channel
for any length of time you'll know that
i'm not the hugest fan of found footage
um there's a lot of exceptions i do
actually like a lot of found footage
movies but
in general it's not a genre that i flock
to this one is kind of more like if i'm
gonna watch a found footage it's gonna
be something more like this one which is
actually a mockumentary which to me is
kind of two different things i mean
found footage is something more like
someone actually found some footage and
they're like we're presenting this
footage of this mysterious thing that we
discovered somewhere uh whereas this one
is much more like
a documentary like a faux documentary
and i tend to like those a little bit
better so most of the found footage
movies i like are actually faux
documentaries so as i said this came out
in 2012 it's canadian and it was written
and directed by christopher mcbride
and i think for a long time even though
i kept seeing this come up on people's
lists of best horror movies of the 21st
century so far even has a very high
rating on rotten tomatoes and stuff i
think probably i was reluctant to watch
it
even after i think it's on 2b for free
if you want to watch it and shutter
added it not too long ago as well which
is where i watched it uh because you
know on shutter i can watch without
commercials but it's on 2b2 if you don't
have shutter so
i think for a long time even after
shutter added i was like oh yeah there's
that movie i should probably get around
to watching that but again if you've
watched this channel for any length of
time you will know that i also have
almost zero patience with conspiracy
theories and with people that are like
super into
trying to like you know sheeple man it's
like i really can't stand people like
that and it's just like so i thought
that even though a lot of people told me
this movie was good i was kind of like
reluctant to watch it because i'm like
is this just going to get on my nerves
um you know what i mean is it just going
to be like some crazy ranty thing and i
was just kind of like so i didn't really
know what to expect going into it
because like i said before i don't
really like to read
reviews of things before i watch them
like sometimes i'll have like a general
idea that oh this one's getting a
positive response in general or this
one's getting a negative response in
general but i don't look into like why
that might be um basically i'm like if
the premise like a one sentence premise
sounds interesting then i'm like okay
well that sounds like something i'll
watch especially if it's getting a
really positive response so i finally
sat down and watched this one and
honestly i'm not really sure why
i slept on this one so long like why it
took so long to watch this one because
this is actually a pretty entertaining
food documentary more i would call it
more thriller than horror
but
it's really kind of doing some
interesting [ __ ]
with conspiracy theory like with the
conspiracy theory mindset and i kind of
think it's interesting too even though
this might have kind of some mildy sort
of spoilers i don't know if i really
want to like spoil the end but i might
do it just because like i said it's hard
to talk about without really talking
about what happens at the end because
one of the things that i liked was how
it ended like the ambiguity of it so i
kind of want to get into that a little
bit as well because i didn't want this
to be a thing and i think that halfway
through this movie because it's not very
long it's only like 84 minutes 88
minutes something like that i was kind
of to the point where well when you set
up a story like this it almost has to go
in the direction of
you know the conspiracy that they're
talking about is real because otherwise
you know you don't really have a story
or it's basically just like a
psychological horizon flag and i feel
like that's a story that could be done
and has been done the thing that the one
movie i thought of in that regard where
someone who
you know was all into like conspiracy
theories or or was essentially a
paranoid schizophrenic um and it was
about that like it didn't turn out to be
real was bug
with michael shannon which is also very
good and i want to get around to that
one of these days too i think it might
be on hulu so i was kind of like well
this is going to turn out oh the
conspiracy is real and all this and i
thought that would just like annoy me
but
i kind of like that the way they
the way uh the filmmaker christopher
mcbride he he almost kind of like had it
both ways
and i thought that was a better approach
because i think that it had some
interesting [ __ ] to say about
the types of people that
fall into these kind of rabbit holes of
like conspiracy theories and also how
easy it is
to
come up with you know if you um
kind of get involved in these circles of
these people talking about stuff
how plausible some of this stuff starts
to seem like the more you go on with it
so i thought it was like kind of it just
didn't go super deep into that because
it is still just kind of like a thriller
photo documentary type thing but it did
kind of touch on those topics one thing
i will say you know i don't know if i
want to call it a trigger warning or
anything like that but this movie does
actually use real footage of real [ __ ]
that happened uh like the 911 attacks uh
jfk assassination stuff like that so if
you're not real jazz about seeing that
uh in a fictional faux documentary about
uh conspiracy theories then maybe give
it a pass because it actually does have
uh real footage in there interspersed
with you know and not only that but
among other things too but interspersed
in with all the fake stuff so
what you have the setup of it is you
have two guys documentary filmmakers and
their names are aaron and jim and those
are their actual names like those are
the actors actual names so again they're
they're doing like a blair witch project
type of thing now uh they're making a
documentary they found a video of this
dude named terence in toronto
who like this video of him he's like out
on the street saying like i said saying
your regular like conspiracy theory type
[ __ ] like you think you're free you're
all slaves you're sheeple blah blah so
he's like saying all this kind of stuff
and he's ranting into a megaphone and
the video goes viral viral like look at
this wacko or whatever so they decide
that they're gonna make a movie
pretty much like about him and like
about all the conspiracy theories that
he's into as they interview him and
actually i really like i think the
actor's name that played uh terence is
alan peterson and he's great in this i
kind of wish he'd been in a little bit
longer because he's super super
believable as
this is the type of person like this is
the type of person that that would sit
next to me on the bus and then like
start ranting about this kind of stuff
like this is exactly that type and it
really came across as like super
believable so they're interviewing him
and he's one of those guys where he
lives in this kind of like you know this
kind of scuzzy apartment and he has he
cuts out all of these uh newspaper
clippings about all these various
historical events
and is drawing uh conclusions or drawing
connections like uh between them right
you know something like
you know and some of the stuff that
happened is like real stuff that
happened like you know gulf of tonkin
and you know it's the pearl harbor and
all this kind of stuff so he's kind of
like trying to tie all these things into
one big grand unified conspiracy theory
essentially uh which i know is kind of a
thing so like i said this
it's a fake documentary and the group
that's supposedly at the center of this
big conspiracy is fake but it's totally
based on
it i don't know it's necessarily based
on real [ __ ] but it's based on real
conspiracy theories that people talk
about you know what i mean they just
don't use the exact same names i mean
they do use a lot of names that come up
in conspiracy theory circles like you
know illuminati and the bilderberg group
and all that kind of stuff so they do
kind of like use that to give legitimacy
to like their [ __ ] so that's what we
have going here so
terence is like convinced that all of
this [ __ ] is connected and that there's
just one shadowy group uh that's at the
center of this is controlling everything
and nobody knows about it and all this
other stuff now
the filmmakers jim is kind of like more
he's like more like me he's more like a
skeptical person where he's just kind of
like you know who is they who is this
that you're talking about do you really
have evidence of all this and everything
but the other filmmaker aaron
actually kind of starts to
believe in terence a little bit in the
sense that he's like oh man that that's
kind of plausible and this is making a
lot of sense and maybe this does connect
to that and isn't that a weird
coincidence that all this stuff happened
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so aaron
is kind of like more of like open to
maybe some of this stuff is true maybe
this guy's not just a loon all this
other kind of stuff which like i said
was really that kind of shit's really
interesting to me because i'm really i'm
not even though i'm not interested in
you know all the dumb [ __ ] like all the
dumb conspiracy theory type [ __ ] i'm
interested in how people get sucked into
them and like the types of people that
get sucked into them i'm interested in
that so that kind of dynamic between the
two filmmakers like when terence was
still there and like one of them you
could tell was kind of like oh man yeah
maybe so you know and he was gonna the
other guy was just like bro no you know
what i mean so i kind of liked that
whole thing which is like the first part
of the movie
now at one point while they're kind of
interviewing terence they're still doing
some [ __ ] with him
and terence has become convinced that
he's being followed uh he says there's
this one guy on a bicycle and he's like
i see that dude all the time i'm sure
that dude is like following me and you
know the filmmakers like see him but
they're like we don't know we've never
seen him before so i don't know but you
know but he's convinced he's like i've
seen that guy before he's following me
around now not too long after this
terence disappears like they for a long
time like the filmmakers they're talking
about calling him and going to his house
and it's like no one's there
we can't figure out where he won't get
in touch with us and it's been weeks and
weeks so finally like i guess his uh
landlord or whatever goes in there
because he hasn't paid rent so it goes
in there to like clean everything out at
which point the landlord lets the
filmmakers kind of go up there and take
like all of his newspaper uh stuff and
everything and at this point they're
kind of like well you know they don't
know if they want to continue with this
documentary or not because
the documentary was kind of about
terence and now he's gone they don't
really know where he went but the the
but the fact of him disappearing uh
gives aaron like even more impetus to
think hey maybe he was on to something
you know and maybe we're starting to get
like in danger or maybe we need to
continue with this project because
obviously he's on the right track and he
wants to find out what the [ __ ] is going
on now one of the things that terence
discovered and that aaron starts to
discover is he goes as he kind of starts
to become obsessed with terrence's
research and going through all of his
stuff that was left in his apartment was
that the pair apparently every single
significant world event
has been
engineered behind the scenes like i said
if you know anything about illuminati or
anything or bilderberg or anything like
that this is very
familiar territory this is something
that you know a lot of conspiracy
theorists like talk about that there's
just this one cabal you know small cabal
of like wealthy people that control
every single significant world event and
that's essentially what this is but this
particular group is called the tarsus
club
and it is kind of based on like an
ancient secret society which
is based in essentially the cult of
mithras uh if you don't know anything
about that uh that was a real thing
but it was kind of like the pre the
precursor to christianity it has like a
lot of the same um mythological elements
as christianity but it was like
thousands of years prior to it and uh it
kind of went had to go underground uh
for a long time so they have found
actually like little secret methodic
artwork or like little places where the
worshipers were and things like that so
it's essentially i don't know if it was
so much a secret society as kind of like
a small cult that was sort of
looked down upon by the by the
authorities uh so they kind of had to
worship in hiding and one of their big
things was um mithras
sacrificing a bull so tarsus club like
uses a bull kind of as their symbol
and um at some point aaron and jim find
that the only mention of the tarsus club
online or they're the only like kind of
article about them
was this article written by a dude named
mark tucker
and uh that guy they can't find anything
about him but they do eventually like
track him down like he's you know going
under a pseudonym or whatever it's all
very shady
and uh so he meets up with them and mark
tucker essentially says you know or or
if this is really mark tucker we don't
really know but he's saying that he is
anyway
uh but he's basically tells them about
the whole myth ray connection and you
know tells them about how long this pla
this uh secret society's been around and
how they're behind pretty much
everything now it turns out and i'm
pretty sure that
uh the filmmaker who made this
got the idea of this particular of the
third act of this movie from that whole
alex jones like supposedly
goes into like the bohemian grove
meeting or whatever like that that was
like a big deal of several years ago so
i kind of feel like that's probably
where because that's essentially like
what the third act of this is like mark
tucker comes to or you know mark tucker
he's uh they don't show him on the his
face is blurred out and his voices uh
you know altered and whatever so he
basically says hey i can get you guys
into the next meeting of the tarsus club
um you know you can sneak in like in the
kitchen like you know with the
wine or whatever so uh so they sneak in
there then there's kind of like some
eyes wide shut sort of thing where it's
like everybody there's like these weird
kind of uh you know rituals where they
you do like a symbolic you know cutting
of
uh rope around and they give people
masks like with ravens and
lions and things like that it's all very
kind of like masonic type of [ __ ]
now at this point
as i said it's in a way like this is a
good movie it's very suspenseful and
it's i just really like the way they go
into
like how people get sucked into this
type of thing so because i think that's
a really interesting thing to explore
but like i said you pretty much know
it's kind of predictable in the sense
that well you know that this tarsus club
this group
some aspects about it are going to turn
out to be real because otherwise you
know it wouldn't be scary or anything
like that so it does kind of go like
that they go and the you know they see
all this weird ritual [ __ ] but one thing
that i like is as i said they the the
ending is left sort of ambiguous you
don't actually know
if like yes this place is real
you know this group is real
but
it's left to your imagination
whether
they
are as nefarious as they've been uh
portrayed
or if people just think that they're
nefarious so in a way they kind of play
along with it or
if they're completely like you know i
don't say they're completely harmless
but you know they don't really have any
like horrific
agenda or anything like that but
people like are kind of like projecting
all of these things on to them um so i
don't like i said i don't want to spoil
the ending exactly because
even though parts of the end are kind of
predictable like i didn't know exactly
how it was going to end like it seems
like it's going to end one way but then
it kind of ends in a slightly different
way and i kind of liked that because i
thought that it was gonna just go and
i'd be like oh well that's like pretty
obvious that was gonna end up like that
but i like that they kind of like gave
it a little thing at the end where it
was just kind of like
wait i don't know maybe maybe not maybe
it's fine maybe the dude's still alive
maybe he's not still alive we don't
really know so i kind of like that they
did it because that's essentially it's
almost kind of like a meta commentary i
guess so like conspiracy theories in
general it's like that but not like in a
self-aware sort of way you know what i
mean like not in that annoying
self-aware like oh look i know what i'm
doing it's meta textual and stuff it's
just to me that kind of just came
through the fabric of the movie if that
makes any sense i'm not really sure if
i'm making any sense but you know when
does that ever stop me not ever so yeah
i mean if you're at all into
faux documentaries which like i said of
all the found footage
sub-genre i tend to like mockumentaries
the best you know because
most pretty much all the found footage
movies i can think of that i like have
been documentaries and this one was
really no exception it's just like you
know it's
it was just like a really decent
suspenseful interesting watch i think
that
because uh you know the whole thing
about conspiracy theories in general
because that whole subculture kind of
gets on my nerves um so that might have
given me like a little bit
of a resistance to it that maybe i
wouldn't have had if i was more like
receptive to this type of mindset which
i'm not
but
even that said i'm glad that i finally
got around to watching it because like i
said i thought that i did i didn't watch
it for a long time because i thought it
was going to get on my nerves but it
didn't get on my nerves like to its
credit so kudos for making a faux
documentary about a bunch of real
conspiracy theories and maybe kind of
like a fake one and it not getting on my
nerves and i actually quite enjoyed it
because i thought it was like pretty fun
so like i said
if this sounds like something uh you'd
be into then it's on i believe it is on
2b for free so you can watch it with ads
or if you have shutter it's on there as
well at least as of this recording so
yeah if you like mockumentaries found
footage stuff like that uh definitely go
check it out it's worth a watch as i
said it's very it's very tense very
suspenseful it's not super gory or
anything like it's not like i said i'd
call it more a suspense thriller
than horror but it does have like some
creepy kind of [ __ ]
going on in it some kind of paranoia uh
type stuff which i think is really well
done so yeah totally decent and uh yeah
i would definitely recommend it so that
will do it for this flickers of fear and
i will see you guys on the next one
bye